[Musique]
un de ces jours il pourra
aller se coucher tout seul mesdames mieux vaut
travailler dur vous avez été embauché pour votre
apparence en fait vous n'étiez pas vous
hmm ça sent bon et n'oubliez pas qu'on doit
encore regarder Real  Les femmes au foyer hey
keV vous savez qui est ma femme au foyer préférée
vous la réunion dans laquelle vous semblez que
tout le monde va vraiment hé les gars vous l'avez
fait
quoi de neuf classe de 99 s nous allons faire la
fête ensemble enfer ouais comme au bon vieux
temps faisons de cette réunion notre chienne
vous  êtes un homme chanceux oz hé les gars vous
devez regarder
oui oui nous devons remuer ressemble à une
fête de lycée avec des filles du lycée
J'adore la nouvelle lune de Twilight Brooks est
mon esprit préféré - oh mon dieu c'est comme si
nous avions tellement  en commun
[Musique]
puis-je vous dire à quel point c'est excitant de voir
tous vos enfants revenir en ville
tu sais papa ça fait trois ans tu
penses qu'il est peut-être temps pour toi de
revenir là-bas
avoir une chance oh non non je ne sais pas  pense donc
Steven je ne le bois pas 300 Ricky
trigger trigger  trigger trigger American
Reunion my QB Je suis la mère de Stifler
oh je suis le père de Jim